eigentlich ist es ein kinderspiel doch
beim so genannten chase sind es
erwachsene menschen die miteinander
fangen spielen wie zum beispiel jenes
maß litsch aus deutschland das ist
fangen noch in ganz ganz anderen level
mit professionellen athleten des tempo
ist um einiges schneller und
dementsprechend auch um einiges
spannender tag wird immer beliebter
in london gab es 2018 die erste
weltmeisterschaft die teams treten in
mehreren runden gegeneinander an
jede runde dauert 20 sekunden 1 team
stellt anfänger das andere den gejagten
entkommt der gejagte erhält sein team
einen punkt gewonnen hat das team das
macht maximal 16 runden die höchste
punktzahl erreicht
[Musik]
für die diesjährige europameisterschaft
in london hat sich auch ein
sechsköpfiges team aus deutschland
qualifiziert sie nennen sich ab und sind
immer dann zur stelle wenn freerunner
und parkour läufer für shows events und
filmprojekte gefragt sind
casetech ist eine entwicklung aus dem
urbanen hindernislauf war es andreas
mühle vom deutschen team umgehen wir zu
machen muss man natürlich schon mit
hindernissen in medien in berührung
gekommen sein das heißt man muss
bewegung techniken drauf haben und wir
sind alle parcours athleten und deswegen
perfekt für dieses spiel die brüder
christian und damien depot haben chase
2011 entwickelt die idee kam den briten
als sie mit ihren kindern im heimischen
garten fangen spielten
wir hatten ein paar gerüste und
experimentiert mit verschiedenen
spielfeld entwürfen die haben sich im
laufe der zeit weiterentwickelt
den ersten wettkampf gab es im dezember
2016 und die videos davon gingen viral
so fing alles an
die wettbewerbe wurden größer und die
athleten immer besser und die community
wächst allein auf ihrem youtube kanal
erzielen die brüder bis zu 26 millionen
klicks pro video bei mehr als 400
tausend abonnenten mittlerweile
veranstalten sie turniere auf der ganzen
welt um den europameistertitel in london
kämpfen heute acht teams bevor es ernst
wird macht sich das deutsche team mit
der arena vertraut und erkundet mögliche
stolperfallen
auch wenn man dann mal schnell den
anderen auffangen will und dann ist die
handball damen nicht da wo sie sein soll
und dann liegt sie vielleicht mal unter
dem körper und dann ist da vielleicht
ein buch oder so aber letztes jahr ging
alles gut und dieses jahr bestimmt auch
dann ist es soweit astaro treten im
ersten match gegen das britische team
bridge an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bereits nach kurzer zeit führen die
briten
und trotz eines sturzes des gegners
können sie gar nicht mehr aufholen
sie scheiden bereits in der vorrunde aus
marc busch vom deutschen team sieht es
gelassen
also sagen
wahrscheinlich werden die straßen gehen
und weiter spielen und trainieren und
spaß haben und wenn es dann in einem
jahr wieder passiert dass wir eingeladen
werden
dann sind wir wieder da am ende ist es
nur ein spiel
das darf man nicht erkennen den titel
holt im finale dieses mal frankreich
doch was zählt ist letztendlich der spaß
am fahren spiel
[Musik]